hallo mein name ist lukrativ willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen akinator video
reuters der viele menschen von mir wird
so aufgeschrieben
luca macht mal wieder die nato ist kam
er so lange nicht mehr nur ich denke mir
jedes mal was soll ich denn da machen
und da das ganze hat so lange nicht mehr
kamen habe ich mir gedacht ich frag den
akinator mal ob er mich überhaupt noch
kennt das ist ja das ganze mal akinator
mini wir sehen schon mal den letzten
zehn spielen da lukas mit war lewis auch
mit dabei alles klar freunde wie sie
zockt ihr das eigentlich den ganzen tag
ich bin 20 jahre alt g20 eine clique
aufspielen leb deine figur in
deutschland also ich spiele jetzt
übrigens mich übrigens auch ganz kurz
warum die letzten drei tage teile videos
kamen jeden den es interessiert kann
kurz halbe minute dran bleiben jeder der
sich sagt er keine halbe minute
vorsprung es ist so viel passiert ich
habe ein neues auto bekommen ich bin
damit nach hause wieder gefahren hat
meinen schlüssel von dem zu hause
allerdings bei meiner familie zu hause
vergessen muss er wieder zurück fahren
konnte dann nicht davon sondern musste
nach frankfurt fahren weil ich zum
hockenheimring musste wegen dem
placement aber ist gerade also wenn ihr
das video seht ist ja sonntag und bis
heute um 12 uhr auf dem hockenheimring
ist es ganz nach 17 uhr wieder zu hause
war zwischendurch noch max besuchen max
krankhafter mit dem neuen video
aufzunehmen ich will einfach jetzt in
zwei drei tagen keine ahnung 1000 1500
kilometer gefahren
deswegen bin ich aber ja deswegen kamen
keine videos tut mir leid aber so eine
lange pause wird es lange nicht mehr
geben weil so lange in zukunft also die
wird wahrscheinlich
wir fangen ja ich lebe in deutschland ja
ich trage männerkleidung meint ich bin
ich bin minecraft letztlich aber nur
teilweise nicht ganz ich klicke trotzdem
mal auf ja er wohnt eine figur balkon
crafter ja kann eine figur unter wasser
grillen degas ist die seite dumm
komplett bescheuert ich also ich wurde
schon gefragt ob meine figur minecraft
player ist ob meine figur bei konkreter
wo ich meine wer sonst wohnt bei mir und
ist minecraft display außer ich und
welcher fucking bastert kann unter
wasser grillen nein ich kann nicht unter
wasser grillen ist eine figur
königliches oberhaupt knapp am winkel
zum ich [ __ ] noch ich wollte nicht
[ __ ] sagen ich wollte verarschen sagen
wird ziemlich [ __ ] sagen glaube ich
nur leute die mittlerweile irgendwie auf
die maschine aus springe
gruppen können und deswegen von allen
ausgelacht und parodiert werden oder
ich bin kein königliches oberhaupt
meines landes ich ja ich habe etwas mit
konkreter zu tun
stark krettek clever batlogg du bist so
dumm sieht mir an dass ich die letzten
vier nächte nie mehr als fünf stunden
geschlafen habe ja ich bin sehr fertig
ja es ist kong kraft und kongress
587.000 mal alles klar zuletzt vor zwei
minuten
ich glaube ich muss nicht mehr fragen ob
ihr süchtig nach dem spiel seid oder
nicht ja hier auch gar nicht mehr
irgendwie vitello und so alle stehen
weil die vitello ist in der schranne in
der schrank die sei nicht alle da drin
außer und kollegen mit der haben wir den
blog gemacht was ich euch hier nochmal
verlinke ich weiß es kann sein dass ich
es vergesse hierzu verlinken sonst
schaut einfach auf meinem kanal nach der
ukulele blog affe war die halt mit dabei
deswegen ist noch nicht wieder bei mir
zuhause deswegen versuche ich jetzt
einfach mal ein kollege zu finden ob es
die noch gibt er ist ein richtiger manly
ich so cool wie männlich tätiger ich
vergebe es immer wieder nein meine
figuren nicht männlich
sie wurde durch youtube bekannt sie hat
keine eigene beauty marke sie ist dann
würde ich sie jetzt am liebsten mal eben
kurz selbst fragen er bis zu einer
beziehung
das
ja nee nee ist in ordnung wenn du meinst
auf jeden fall so machen okay okay wir
sehen uns wir sehen uns ökologisch
definitiv nicht in einer beziehung aber
sie hat gedacht das kind vielleicht sagt
er ich bin alter meine augen sind ja so
fertig nein wie es in keiner beziehung
sie hat nicht mehr als 1000 abos sie ist
kein mensch sie ist nicht auf sgm aktiv
ja sie kommen dass eine ukulele im
geschäft sie steht gerade nicht in
meinem zimmer aber ich klicke einfach
mal auf ja und es ist cool eli und
ukulele wurde auch schon 340.000 malich
man theoretisch besteht akinator video
machen bei lugano daraus sich selbst zu
suchen und im kollegium so und dann
schauen wie viele schon gespielt wurden
und dann ich hab mir grad eine kasse vor
mir liegen kann sein dass man das
cockpit finden kann trägt eine figur
eher männliche kleidung ist eine figur
deutsche youtube hat eine figur etwas
mit musik zu tun
deine figur justin bieber zu tun also
das video ist allein schon 27 jahre her
und das kind es da also ich denke ich
bin auch keine ahnung man meine figur
wurde nicht zusammen mit einer band
berühmt ist nicht älter als 18
ich habe keine ahnung wir hatten nichts
mit costa cordalis zu tun sie ja ich
weiß nicht ob sie ihre kleine schwester
sieht nicht durch musiklabel emi sie
unternimmt nicht viel mit anderen
youtube sie hat blonde haare
woher soll ich das wissen wenn ich
begriff kein dj sie kommt ja aus amerika
sie habt ja ein handy wie ich weiß nicht
ob die über 20 foto fox brand stores ein
paar sekunden später bremst als sie
tatsächlich sehr sehr crazy aus es ist
nicht nur ein staat ja ich möchte
fortfahren sie ist kein youtuber sie ist
nicht weiblich sie ist ja sie ist durch
das internet bekanntgeworden ist deine
figur ein erwachsener mann nein ist eine
die amerikanerin ja denn über schwarze
haut nein
alter schwede
der clever bord haut echt immer überaus
ja es ist jonathan ok heißt jonathan das
car kit ok ja und er wurde sechsmal
wurde der hits gespielt war worte [ __ ]
you das war's dann auch schon mit diesem
video ich habe jetzt mich gesucht
ukulele und das car kit beim karaoke
zeit tatsächlich 10.000 jahre gedauert
er ich das gefühl habe ich mich über
eine bewertungen freuen habt ihr bock
auf mehr akinator weiterhin in zukunft
dann schreibt man die kommentare beim
solche sachen wie alu kwh müssen die
alten formate also clever bord akinator
so was in die richtung aber ich weiß
nicht wie ich das nochmal noch cool
aufbauen kann weil es keine endlos
projekte in bezug auf trevor boyd
versuche ich damit dem murphy bot schon
so ein bisschen zu arbeiten der auch
ganz cool ist vielleicht jetzt war die
nato auch eine andere möglichkeit oder
so aber schreibt dass man die kommentare
und dann sehen wir uns wieder